as fans worldwide wait in anticipation
for the final part of attack on titan to
be animated
and manga readers find themselves with a
gaping hole in their heart as the manga
is now over
be it a good or a bad thing the 12 year
old series is taking a long
needed break from the spotlight and thus
this gives us
ample time to look back a space for
retrospection to once again
admire the moments that have taken the
series far off the ground
and elevated it to the heights it now
rests upon among the most
famous and notorious anime of all time
and there are plenty of scenes and parts
to choose from
but in my eyes there is a single episode
that stands far
above the rest episode 31
warrior the moment that shocked millions
across the world in one of anime's best
and most climactic betrayals
ever from the subtle hints throughout
the episode showing the breakdown
of reiner's facade to the slow and
dramatic build up that defies what we
would expect
to simply the animation and the
soundtrack itself
this episode is a masterpiece
and today i'm talking about all of that
and more
in the anime episode that shook the
world
the episode begins with a recap of what
happened in the previous episode which
is the reveal that ymir was
actually a titan shifter showing her
transformation
in the heat of the moment to defend
historia burt holtz and
reiner against titans and the last
minute arrival of the scouts to save the
day
this context before the episode though
it might just seem like a recap
is key in re-establishing the sense of
mistrust
and mystery among the core and the
viewers
it's the first reminder in this season
since annie was revealed to be a titan
in season one
that there could be in fact more titan
shifters and traitors among them
that there actually probably are
but what none of us would have expected
however is how soon that mistrust would
come to fruition
later this episode
we then move on to the aftermath of the
battle all of the core have gathered on
top of the walls still
reeling from the injuries sustained by
yamir and reiner
and the close call they experienced
aaron helping the injured reiner to the
top of the wall with a smile
as historia pleads with hanji to see
that yamir
is a good person and was fighting to
defend them as well as the new reveal of
her true name as historia
this episode is also already
demystifying many questions that have
been laid out in the series
ymir's identity historias very typical
of what happens after a big battle in
any anime
we are given a moment of peace to digest
everything going on
and offered new pieces of information to
question
where the series will go on from here
it is the end of one arc and the
beginning of another
only seven minutes into this episode
were already being set up
to expect new reveal after reveal and
it doesn't stop building up here
and then comes the first conversation
between aaron and
reiner reiner begins by complaining
about how pathetic he is because he
almost got killed by a titan
how his wound hurts and he couldn't do
anything and how it's actually his
second time that he's almost died
he then restates his goal and the survey
corps goal of plugging the wall
and how there's no time to waste until
they do that
and despite what we know now as people
who have watched this episode
who know what reiner's been through what
he's saying here
almost feels too realistic to just be
acting
and it's because he has in fact lost
himself
up to this point reiner is so immersed
into the life he has here on paradise
island
believing he's a normal scout and that
his main mission
is to plug the hole in the wall that he
created five years ago
this is genuinely what reiner believes
and what he's turned into
but then berdholtz reminds him of what
they're here to do
he reminds him of their hometown
and again reveal after reveal harness
comes and
informs them that there is in fact no
hole in the wall
what they believed to be titans coming
in through an opening were actually
somehow being produced in
another way again it leaves the viewer
in a constant state of
questioning and mistrust as we think
about everything being thrown at us
but then among all these new pieces of
information
reiner comes out of nowhere with one of
the most unexpected
and understated reveals ever
there's no soundtrack at all just the
noise of the wind upon the wall
the reveal that five years ago reiner
and bertholdt destroyed the wall
and that they are the titans what should
be the biggest
and most climactic reveal of the show so
far
feels like just a typical conversation
as it clashes with
hanji's talk with another scout on the
other side of the wall
the show purposefully belittles and
makes this conversation
seem like it's nothing even reiner's way
of saying it
is casual as if he isn't committing the
ultimate betrayal to one of his best
friends
the camera is constantly moving between
the two separate talks as if they're
equally important
as we get shocked with this huge news we
are in this ultimate state of
confusion and subversion and then the
music returns
and the viewer realizes wait
is he actually serious because of the
subtlety of the moment we are just as
shocked as aaron is to hear these words
coming out of reiner's mouth
as if it's nothing and then were thrown
into a flashback from 12
hours earlier
the flashback shows the reveal that
reiner and bert holt came from the same
place as
annie did in the past and how their
records are all spotty
that every member of the corps found out
that reiner and bertholds were extremely
suspect
and almost confirmed to be traitors
hours before the reveal
every moment of force shadowing up until
this point is witnessed shocking the
entire core
and the viewers who haven't realized
until now
and here i have to mention how
completely unexpected from a writing
standpoint
the mystery and build up for reiner and
bertholdt's characters
occurs after the actual reveal
because of the context of the previous
scene it actually works
extremely well instead of a typical
build up to a single reveal
in one climactic moment the episode
turns this format on its head
it separates the reveal from the climax
and this is what's so beautiful about it
it sustains our disbelief and surprise
throughout the entire
episode without ruining the climax of it
and in these last moments before the
climax when they actually
transform we see one main thing
reiner's snap his snap back to reality
he questions what was i thinking have i
actually gone
crazy as aaron tells him that what he's
saying is absurd and tries to plead with
him in the hopes that he's just joking
around
even though they both know that he's not
of course the timid birdhole
tries to go along with it fitting with
his character who has
always followed reiner's more ambitious
lead
and then the flag falls the characters
turn
the skies clear the most iconic
soundtrack of the series
cues in this silent moment this
is it what we've been waiting for
reiner explains his regrets in the
exciting reveal that we were expecting
10 minutes earlier the screaming the
soundtrack the
tears the shocked expressions
satisfaction that we were stripped of
earlier in this episode has
finally arrived mikasa attacks
screaming for aaron to run but he can
only stand shocked
and now i have to of course mention the
soundtrack because it works
so absolutely beautifully with this
scene
what goes from soft expositional almost
synthetic piano like notes during
reiner's story
turns into intense coral synths as
reiner and bertholdt
turned the clear sky yellow with their
transformation
reiner's intense look contrasted by
bertholdt's tears and shock
jaws dropped the beauty of this moment
is that we've known for almost the
entire episode now that they are
traitors
but somehow our jaws are still dropped
at the climax here
the episode somehow told us the truth so
early on but managed to sustain our
surprise throughout
the beauty of this strange format and
build up has
unexpectedly led to one of the greatest
episode conclusions
ever as tears roll down aaron's face
he recalls reiner who was once like an
older brother to him
and the times they shared just like us
viewers
he was left in disbelief throughout the
entire episode in perpetual shock
but by the end with their transformation
that sealed the deal
we all know for good his pleas for
reiner to make sense to remind them of
the time they've spent together
are gone now all they are
are traitors very few times has an
episode left
me wanting this much from the end of it
being left in a state of
absolute disbelief despite the fact that
the reveal happened
actually like 15 minutes ago midway
through
the whole 25 minute episode was just
beautifully crafted
and it was one of the best executions of
this kind of moment i have ever
personally seen
what do you guys think of it i know it's
probably been a while since most of you
have seen it but i'm sure
none of you have forgotten it leave a
comment down below
as always this has been the anime
culture owner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga
and character analyses
you